welcome to the very first stronger by
science fireside chat
I'm your host Greg knuckles joined by
for the time being a temporary
provisional guest host named Eric
Trexler Eric thanks for joining me yeah
I really appreciate the invitation this
is a really big opportunity I'm not
gonna let you down all right so let's uh
let's dive on into it so if you didn't
listen to the last normal episode of the
podcast we talked about how we're going
to start some more just short term or
short form fun content where you know
I'm sure Fitness stuff will come up but
that's not you know that that's not the
the purpose of it it's mostly just two
buddies chatting about random stuff so I
put out on social media hey hit us with
your questions the more
out-of-left-field the better
apparently out of left field - whoo -
most of our audience means fitness
questions specifically how do I workout
without a gym if that is something that
interests you we just put an article up
on the website that you can check out
but we were looking for non fitness
related questions so quite a few did
come in we're gonna bring them up we're
gonna chat about them and let's see how
it goes I will say it was very
disappointing some of those out of left
field questions were word-for-word
questions that are asked on the normal
Q&A like I think it's the same people
who are just like cool another avenue
for my question
yeah which is fine like I get it but
that that's not what we're doing for
these episodes so let's hop right into
it quite a few people asked what sort of
media do we consume just movies and TV
shows what are we watching these days
what kind of stuff do we enjoy so do you
want to kick it off I do because I want
to start with an enormous disclaimer
anyone that knows me in real life knows
that I don't consume the film in any
capacity whatsoever
I've probably watched a total of I don't
know maybe 11 movies since I was born
and the thing is it's not a conscious
decision so it's not like I'm like ah
these movies are trash I'm out every
time I watch a movie I go wow what a
medium like that was a really
entertaining ride but for some reason
it's like the I think the time scale of
it mm-hmm I just can't wrap my head
around sitting down and focusing on it
for two hours sometimes two and a half
but but yeah I'm gonna be mostly useless
in this conversation but no yeah I mean
I I don't disagree and what we're going
to discuss in the second half of this
episode is work-life balance and I feel
like you've already partially alluded to
how we're both going to respond to that
question like yeah it's not it's
trivially easy to carve out 30 minutes
to watch something not that hard to
carve out an hour to watch an episode of
TV it is kind of challenging to carve
out to or if you're talking about
driving to the movie theater three hours
to watch something yeah so that that is
very understandable and it's not even
that I don't have the time to spare it's
that there's almost like a sticker shock
where I look at I go you know a hundred
and twenty minutes you have to be
kidding there's no way I could possibly
do that even though I yeah I totally
have 120 minutes but but so one of the
things we do is every week when it's in
season we get together and watch
Westworld yeah that's um well started
with Game of Thrones but that's actually
how we started hanging out we knew each
other before this but when I enrolled in
the grad program at UNC my wife and I
were into indie game of thrones invited
Eric over to see if he wanted to watch
Game of Thrones with us he had like a
standing weekly Game of Thrones date
with another girl in the program named
Jenna
so they started coming over and we
started watching Game of Thrones
together and I mean I would I would say
that's kind of how we became buddies I
would say so I do want to clarify you
used the term date there that was
metaphorical I don't want any salacious
rumors starting on the podcast here
Jenna and I were not dating
well yes standing
called it an appointment no an
appointment between colleagues a date
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
in like a relationship way I'm just
trying to get out ahead of these rumors
because fair enough my girlfriend might
listen to this and I'd like to get out
ahead of it okay okay but but no yeah
Jenna and I would get together and watch
Game of Thrones and we kind of merged it
all into one big game of Thrones viewing
party but yeah now we're watching West
world and it's pretty solid I'm gonna be
honest I have no idea what's happening I
have I been hiding that or is that clear
no that's clear have you watched season
one yet yes okay yeah so so like I said
we started by watching Game of Thrones
together Lindsey and I were super into
west world so West world season two
rolls around and we're like dude we got
a watch West world together we get
through the first episode and Eric looks
kind of lost and then it turns out
[ __ ] haven't watched season 1 I
mean I'm a confident young man and I
figured you know what I I have the
intellect to support this I'm just gonna
dive in on season 2 turns out that's a
complicated plot Wes world is a show
that confuses you even if you are
obsessed with it and you know everything
that's going on like that's kind of its
trick you know that's part of that's one
of the reasons it is so easy to get
sucked in because it invites fan
theorizing and so if you missed an
entire season of content you are
light-years behind
yeah now I will say this in the interest
of fairness at first I thought it was
funny that I was so confused I still
enjoyed it I guess if you don't know
what's happening and you jump into
season 2 you're basically just watching
an old western yeah which is fun enough
well and what I will say is like season
two was more confusing than season 1 so
I don't actually think you were that
much more confused than anyone else well
but that's what I was about to get to is
so I watched season 2 in its entirety
and then I was like wow when I go back
and watch season
one boy am I really gonna get it
honestly I still don't I I think I need
to get on some kind of like forums or
message boards to figure some of this
stuff out I try to pick up like Lindsay
talks about it a lot and she seems to
make some sense of it but I have no idea
what's going on well so one of the
things you need to understand about
Lindsay and how she she consumes media
is when she gets really into a show she
will watch the hour of content for that
show
and then she'll listen to between two
and four hours of podcasts about the
episode she just watched so if when I'm
confused watching something and I mean
she doesn't do this for every show
obviously like there's there's a finite
number of hours in the day and there's a
finite number of podcasts but she was
like this for Game of Thrones she's like
this for Westworld she does this for for
a couple other shows but only the ones
she's super super into she is out there
making sure that she is as caught up as
a human could be but yeah if you're if
you're just watching the show as it
comes as it comes out
I feel like West world does a pretty
good job of explaining what you have
just seen over the last 10 hours of the
previous season in the last episode or
two but up until that point like it is
it is a pretty wild ride and you're
never quite sure what's going on yeah
she kind of treats her entertainment
like the like the game-changers universe
where it's like is it like ninety
minutes of content sure but that doesn't
mean you can't have a 16 hour podcast
about it correct you know and then maybe
a 60,000 word article about that so I
I'm sure she's probably gotten into all
the all the details on game changers as
well but so Westworld is going on what
else you watching these days I mean I
figure we shouldn't leave the west-world
discussion there like I don't know
anything about it what do you like about
Wes world what what character do most
strongly identify with
I don't want to admit this but by far my
favorite character in season 2 was like
the you know the the the man in black is
that what they call him yeah he was
awesome I mean he was terrible literally
the worst person completely despicable
but a very complicated character mm-hmm
and I think that's my favorite thing in
any kind of entertainment is I like the
characters that are extremely
complicated that you're like you know
what I hate you but in a pretty good way
yeah you know like he was so interesting
and hard too it was hard to look away a
lot of the scenes where he was featured
so I'm not gonna lie so far in the new
season we haven't seen him yet which to
me is a huge bummer I'm I was
complaining about that privately the
other night I wish he would come back am
I am i imagining this or did you go to
like a Halloween party dressed up as old
William one time I did but it's even
worse than that okay I used to
so he's like an absolute piece of trash
like a unspeakably bad person and so I
used to tell my girlfriend that I really
identify with that character just to
kind of bother her like this is who
you're dating but so I got the costume
as a joke but I wasn't able to go out
that Halloween yeah and so it's even
worse because I went as him a year after
he was relevant if I went at the right
time it would have been like Eric SiC
William costume but I wouldn't year
later it was like why are you wearing a
hat like what is happening you're
wearing a hat and gloves I don't get it
that's amazing because like his hat
isn't even shaped like a typical cowboy
hat yeah so it just didn't work at all
yeah and yeah it was it was a disaster
my girlfriend was supposed to go as one
of the other characters she bailed so it
was kind of like that Always Sunny
episode where they were supposed to go
was like Mario and Luigi and one went as
Aragorn
from Lord of the Rings yeah and he's
like dude now I'm just like a creepy
Italian plumber it was like that I was
like just some creepy dude in a hat
that's amazing so yeah Westworld we both
love it it's a very fun show especially
if you don't mind being confused it is
not a show to watch casually it's not a
show to like put on as background noise
when you're doing chores but if you
really want to get sucked into a TV show
West world is super good art are you
currently watching anything else um I
want to start watching Deb's I just
watched a bunch of Always Sunny mm-hmm
so like my my bench in terms of show
references we've already reached the end
of it I made one I made one always sunny
reference that's all I got I mean I
might have a Seinfeld reference or two
in me but but I fear that I'm gonna
become less and less relevant as this
conversation progresses but I'm gonna do
my best I hate to admit this so I also
love always sunny like I would say 90%
of the episodes I've watched gets good
at least one belly-laugh out of me I'm
only like midway through season 3 you're
kidding me well I've also watched all of
season either 10 or 11 they had it on an
airplane and this was like a
trans-pacific flight so I meant to get
work done on the airplane and I did I
did in my defense this was when I had
like an older laptop that was too large
and so it wouldn't open all the way on
an airplane wasn't I on this flight no I
think this was another one and so yeah
like the person and so I could I could
get it barely open enough to to do work
if the seat in front of me was up but as
soon as you know as soon as it became
night in the person in front of me laid
their seat back
I literally just could not work so I
watched an entire season of always sunny
which which was terrible for everyone
around me because I I'm not someone who
suppresses laughter
when I find something funny I [ __ ]
laugh and people can deal with that yeah
so I I definitely kept everyone around
me for for probably the better portion
of 5 hours so I've watched like one of
the later seasons and like the first
three seasons but dude it's so funny you
know they're on season like 14 right
yeah yeah it's I'm devastated to hear
that you have mostly caught the early
part because they followed a trajectory
this is gonna much like Seinfeld so
there's my second reference that I'm
done but they follow that same
trajectory where they started as like
hey let's try to make a show with
characters that might theoretically
exist and then after a while there's
only so many funny circumstances that
you can insert those characters into
mm-hm and much like with Seinfeld
they're like okay Plan B everyone's
gonna become despicable in the funniest
ways we're not even going for anything
resembling normal life and they just
lean into it so hard and so the
character development goes totally off
the rails
the plots go totally off the rails and
it just gets better and better
it's like you keep expecting like okay
this season that's gonna fall off and it
just doesn't know yeah so my my
experience with Always Sunny is I had
not watched it so I didn't have like
cable for most of the time I was growing
up and so I didn't get into it when it
was new I never seen it before we were
friends at this point so like you had
recommended it to me very hard I watched
an entire season on an airplane and that
was my that was my first exposure to it
and so I told Linds like hey wanna know
I was laughing the whole flight and
keeping everyone around me awake the
whole time I watched that show
Eric told us about it was super funny we
should check it out so we pulled it up
on Hulu and started on season 1 and
there were it was good I mean like I
found it entertaining but it wasn't as
good
as the entire season I'd watched on the
airplane and now I'd like the the back
half of season 3 things seem to be
ramping up like following that
trajectory he talked about yeah god damn
that shows funny though you must have
just been absolutely stunned when you
went back and started season 1 and
you're like this isn't what I was
watching I mean it is a tangible
different show yeah you know but but
yeah you've got a lot of entertainment
ahead of you for sure
do you always sunny is also it's it's my
favorite show to bring up as a trump
card whenever someone says like everyone
so easily offended these days like I
watched this very off-color movie or TV
show in the 80s and like no way could it
get made today just like are you aware
of Always Sunny in Philadelphia like
it's it's probably more off-color than
any other piece of media that has been
that long running maybe with the
exception of South Park that is very
true but I think the thing that's
fascinating about it is if you watch an
episode and you talk to somebody who
theoretically would be like in the
wheelhouse of I know who would be very
offended by that you know what I mean
someone where the thing that you you
just can't say that they're talking
about like it would be very personal to
them yeah yeah whenever you have that
opportunity like the people who should
be offended by are like not who they
nailed it like it was the way they
approach it is they're not taking cheap
shots at people or just using it for
shock value they actually approach the
topics really effectively in my opinion
like they have a way of doing it where
it's like you said like you're still
allowed to do comedy but like just try
to suck less at it oh yeah yeah if your
only approach to comedy is like I'm just
gonna make a lot of people mad and
there's gonna be no like actual wit
behind it mm-hmm
yeah I guess maybe you're not allowed to
do that as much anymore but why did you
ever do it in the first like it's just
not it's not good that honestly is
just one of my favorite genres of comedy
just just purely for the irony of it
where you know you're just like oh man
the like you know the people are trying
to shut me down they're saying I can't
tell these jokes anymore
they're silencing me and it's like the
14th neck Netflix special at the last 12
months where that's been the general
theme of it it's like so you say this
yet you probably got a seven-figure deal
to make this comedy special and there's
like dozens that are exactly like it
seems like maybe you're not actually
being silenced that would be that would
be one way to interpret the revolving
door of contracts that their game yeah
all right so that's always Sonny so you
mentioned Deb's you haven't started it
yet no we're we're called up I believe
if we're behind it's like one episode
behind it's good it's um it's I mean
like it's a serious show it's not it's
not something you want to put on if you
know you're just trying to to tune out
and look for some escapism it's it's
almost like an entire season of TV
that's like a black mirror episode so
are we doing spoilers oh that's a good
question
this is currently ongoing tonight we did
one a prep work for this I don't think
we covered we did absolutely no prep
work for this yeah let's let's not do
spoilers yeah but yeah so it's it's like
vaguely dystopian it's Ron Swanson is a
crazy tech genius dude what's his name
again I'm so bad with Nick off Nick
Offerman yeah I've come to realize I'm
never going to watch him in any piece of
media and not immediately think it's Ron
Swanson yeah because I so it wasn't
until pretty recently that I saw an
interview with Nick Offerman to see you
know what is this dude actually like
what this his voice sound like
sometimes that throws me for a loop so
another another show that that Lyndsey
and I watched was called the Americans
it's about like Soviet spies living as
as Americans and doing undercover stuff
and one of the actors in that show I
believe is is Welsh or Scottish I think
Welsh but he does he does a flawless
American accent and I just assumed he
was an American dude and the first time
I saw an interview with him I was like
holy [ __ ] what's going on right now
anyway it was not like that with Nick
Offerman Nick Offerman's voice is Ron
Swanson yeah and I don't think he ever
affects a voice for any character ever
so it's just Ron Swanson voice coming
out of everyone's mouth in so I I'm also
like that like if if I see a character
in a role that that they just absolutely
nail that is who they are to me forever
um so oh man another thing to note is I
think I partially do this as a defense
mechanism because I'm really bad with
names
so not only pronouncing names but
remembering names and so I got it Hugh
Laurie so Hugh Laurie my mom loved house
when I was growing up yeah yeah and so
there was a BBC show a while back called
the night manager with Loki as the hero
I don't remember that guy's name Tom
Hiddleston yes dude I'm doing pretty
well today this isn't bad so he's he's
the hero and house m.d. is an
international arm smuggler and so that's
how I always describe it to people
because house m.d. comes to mind way
before Hugh Laurie does yeah people are
like what the [ __ ] that sounds like the
weirdest spin-off ever yeah I'm like no
no it like it's the actor I don't
remember his name
[Music]
anyway devs so yeah it has Ron Swanson
as a as a crazy tech guy there's like
some murders and a lot of tech stuff
without giving away any of the plot
be difficult to describe why the show
was good but it is it is very engrossing
I'd highly recommend it yeah I the
reason that I want to watch it is I
actually I saw an advertisement for it
when I was watching Always Sunny on Hulu
I think and anything with Nick Offerman
I'm like yeah I'll give it a shot
because him as Ron Swanson was probably
one of my favorite things in the just
under the concept of television like any
type of television entertainment him as
Ron Swanson is very high at the top of
my list he speaks to me in a way that no
other character can and it got to the
point some of my colleagues in grad
school would weekly remind me hey did
you know that you actually are Ron
Swanson and so it was like it's almost
like he's my alter ego or part of me in
a way I'm we currently work with Ron
Swanson what Mike's Ordos maestro Mike
is the man
so his I don't know if he's changed this
but I don't want to lie I think it's his
university email address it might be his
personal email address but one of the to
like his his like signature has several
Ron Paul quotes at the bottom one of
them one of them in and I don't know if
this is still the case but it used to be
it was like the government hates theft
because it doesn't like competition but
like he works for a state university
which which to me is exactly the same as
Ron Swanson but a hyper libertarian but
working for the parks department I think
I think ideologically Zoar dose is a
much better Swanson impersonator but I
think just in terms of being a general
curmudgeon I think that's really what
what would is caused causing the the
equivalence there between me and Ron is
just being the grumpiest most
curmudgeonly person possible yeah yeah
but but no I I definitely want to see
Deb's it's going to be
interesting to watch him in a different
role but I'm sure he's gonna be great
I agree um so yeah last TV show not
currently watching it's currently all
fair I don't actually know if it's gonna
come come back but it was it was a show
that I think that way too few people
watched like I didn't I didn't see a ton
of people talking about it and I feel
like they should have been because it
was super good and that is Fargo I think
it was on FX and that there are either
three or four seasons and so if you've
seen the Coen Brothers movie Fargo
Season one of the TV show is basically
just like an expanded version of that
movie which so both of us watch way more
TV than films and I think one of one of
the benefits of the medium is that if
you have a complex plot and a very
character-driven story which the Fargo
movie is a very character-driven movie
you can just you can do that better in
the television medium I think just
because you have a longer runtime you
can show more about the characters like
get the audience more invested in the
characters you know you can you can tell
a more complex story so season one of
Fargo is in my opinion an improved
version of the Fargo movie and then the
next two seasons tell completely
different stories within the same like
Fargo universe and oh man so they're
they're like crime kind of like
Detective II type stories they have very
very interesting plots very very rich
characters and this could just be like
my cultural prejudice as as a southern
person but I in my opinion the the show
maintains like a good sense of levity
because there's at least one or two
characters in every season that have an
incredibly thick Minnesota accent
and I don't know to me that's just a
very good vibes accent oh for sure
very good accent yeah I haven't seen
Fargo I'm gonna be honest I'll probably
never get to it I have a that's fairly
narrow scope of of what's on my to watch
list when someone like gives me a show
and they're like hey you should watch
this I I find it to be so offensive
where I'm like how dare you commit me to
several hours of anything one honorable
mention this is I I did that to you I
told you you gotta reinvest in peaky
blinders mm-hmm such a cool show don't
have time to get into all of it because
we'll probably want to move on soon but
big time recommendation you're missing
out that show is sweet the main
character is dead inside there's just no
life behind his eyes whatsoever and much
like much like the man in black from
West world
I just I'm a sucker for a main character
that's dead inside I mean like I mean
even Ron Swanson is mostly dead inside
mm-hmm something about that just calls
to me I don't want to thank too much
about it I don't want to get too
introspective about that yeah but that
that character to me I just I don't know
it's so intriguing we have to mention
one movie I think we haven't mentioned a
movie yet have we we haven't we said it
was gonna be movies and TV so I'm gonna
yield the floor for the movie second
here's a fun movie fact for everyone
that'll work that's enough related to
the the temporary guest co-host sitting
across from me right now
when Avengers in game came out so so one
thing just to know about me and my
movie-watching habits is like I'm not
I'm not really a theater person it's
it's a lot of money like you got a drive
there it's like a whole big thing you
you have to go at a particular time
where there's a showing like whatever
it's not it's not my bag most of the
movies i watch in the theaters these
days are marvel films just because like
if I'm going to spend the time and money
to watch some
in theaters I wanted to be an action
movie for the most part just because I I
do feel like you know big action
sequences do titillate the senses better
on the big screen with like 5.1 Dolby
surround sound like it's a whole thing
and I think that for you know like
dramas or like suspense movies or
whatever you get the same for me
personally I get the same vibe from it
watching it at home when it comes out on
video or well I guess when it's put on a
streaming platform I haven't watched a
video and so long it's really criminal
that they moved away from the VHS format
VHS was solid very dependable they would
never break it's a shame
we can agree to disagree I don't know if
I should tell this but I will anyways so
what one thing about VHS tapes which
which made them more user-friendly for
people who were Luddites and didn't want
to learn how to use software is you
could more easily edit a piece of media
in a very analog fashioned so I I've
told you this before so you know you
know where I'm going with this yeah
so I I grew up in like a young earth
creationist household and I've loved
land before time like that that was my
[ __ ] growing up land before time and
winnie-the-pooh and Power Rangers those
were those were like the three media
franchises that I was that I was all
about and in the intro to Land Before
Time it was just like millions of years
ago dinosaurs roamed the earth it's like
it's like a voiceover thing at the start
of the at the start of the film so like
my my my parents got like the Land
Before Time VHS we watched it together
as a family and that came on and like my
parents had to pause and be like so
first off that's [ __ ]
and then so one of the things you can do
with VHS tapes is like you can open the
tape up you can find the like individual
physical frames that are that are bad
and take scissors and cut them out and
then like I think I think some people
would just tape it back together I think
she used heat to like yeah like kind of
weld the tape back together and so I
mean like I've probably watched Land
Before Time 50 or 60 times like that
that was my jamm growing up but I only I
only ever heard about how long ago
dinosaurs roamed the earth the first
time we saw it together I just like to
imagine you watching it at a friend's
house and being like dude did you get
like the director's cut when did they
start doing bad the Peter Jackson
extended edition yeah its Land Before
Time but it's actually seven hours long
yeah all sorts of deleted action scenes
where was I going with this movies okay
so just back on the general concept of
movies so yeah like most of oh dude I
remember what I was talking about we got
way off topic yeah so yeah mostly watch
stuff from the theaters or mostly watch
stuff just when it comes out on video
only action stuff is what I watch from
the theaters for the most part so when
in game came out most of our friends had
been watching the Marvel films or you
know had watched enough of them that
they were more or less up-to-date on the
plot [ __ ] tracks had watched zero
Marvel movies before in game came out I
don't even know the character names but
he came to watch in game with the group
how did that go I mean it's it's a
simple enough story that it was pretty
straightforward to follow right I just
kind of assumed it was an Eric Holmes
biopic like I was like one of these
characters looks familiar no it was it
was pretty simple the guy with the
really purple skin seemed generally
disliked yeah yeah yeah it was fine I
there was a lot of action it was
good stuff Robert Downey jr. was was
really good at it you know he's a good
actor yeah so I mean it was good I liked
it I thought it was easy enough to
follow but there were certain key times
in the film where someone would do
something or say a line and like you
would you could tell based on the vibe
in the theater that an important thing
happened it was like supposed to be a
callback or something yeah it was either
like a callback or a joke or like
something that would make you gasp and I
would I I missed a hundred percent of
those yeah sure so there was certainly
some impact to the film that I wasn't
feeling but generally speaking it was
you know it was close enough I mean that
that's kind of my experience viewing
most things as I dive in toward the very
end or kind of midstream like with West
world and I'll be like I think I can
piece this together I usually don't but
I never learned yeah but yeah so in
terms of films that I have seen you know
I shouldn't say films movies one of
these is I would say a film the other
the other ones are movies important
distinction but in terms of stuff that
that's still in theaters pumping them
out all the time I enjoy the Marvel
movies they're not intellectually
challenging but they're big and fun and
I think they're enjoyable and theaters
same thing with the Fast and Furious
movies like here's one thing I'll say I
wanna clean of those movies and I think
that like I think a lot of people
watched Fast and Furious like one two
and three and they're like oh whatever
like this isn't really my bag like their
movies for people who are very very into
car culture but they're not just like
kind of stock action movies and after I
believe Fast and Furious Five they did
just become like big fun stupid action
movies which work really really well on
the big screen so if you haven't watched
a fast and furious film since like
[ __ ] 1990 mounting or whatever you
should check them out there
fun the most recent one was the first
spin-off it was Hobbes and Shaw so it's
it's the rock and dang it
the bald guy Statham yeah yeah Jason
Statham so I didn't think it was quite
as fun as you know when the whole crew
is together yeah I mean those are fun
movies to watch in theaters I think the
the recent film that you were gonna say
something I was gonna say my experience
with fast and furious is the most
predictable story of all time oh
absolutely I mean but my personal as you
can imagine I dove in you know very late
in the series but that was one instance
it's not like diving into Westworld yeah
yeah so I had an ex-girlfriend who was
like it's my birthday
I love these films I want you to take me
to see the new Fast and Furious it was
like you know fast and furious 26 or
whatever it was and we're on the way to
the theater and she goes I'm gonna go
ahead and explain the plot to you and I
remember I remember just kind of smugly
chuckling and being like I think I'll
get it yeah yeah but yeah there was one
character who forgets a lot of things
that was an important plot point and
everything else I pieced together that's
like that's like the closest thing to
even marginally complicated
relationships so like yeah in the first
few movies like you know the the FBI guy
is like you know kind of working with
the car thieves for like kind of loyal
to the FBI like whatever and then like
in some of the more recent ones like
Letty gets amnesia or whatever but yeah
I mean they're you don't have to think
too hard when when you're watching them
they're just big fun movies which which
do play so much better on the big screen
than like a home TV system and there's
kind of a universal language when you
see Dwayne the rock Johnson flex and
bust out of a cast with a broken limb
you don't need a backstory you
understand
exactly what's happened absolutely by
the way he never got his people never
got back in touch about co-hosting the
podcast would you believe that it's a
damn shame yeah so I moved on so the
movie I have seen pretty recently which
is more on the film side of things than
the movie side of things is knives out I
think I got some Oscar buzz this past
year I don't really follow entertainment
industry stuff but solve add in theaters
it was I went into it with like kind of
low expectations Mac as I thought it
would be bad but just because it did
seem like kind of a character-driven
thing just watching the the previews and
the commercials for it and so I kind of
I kind of expected it to be a story or
I'd be like you know I kind of wish that
there was more of this and that it was a
TV show instead of a movie but ya know
it was a nice fun little self-contained
murder mystery it was really well done
very slick it was something where I
would have been just as happy to watch
it on a TV as in the theater but it was
a fun story and I would highly highly
recommend checking it out awesome are
you ready to move on from the TV and
film segment let's move on all right so
we got a question on Facebook I'll just
read the question we can go from there
the question was how have we managed to
keep work-life balance you came to the
right place I could tell you that Greg
why don't you start how do you do it so
well so as I do so often in Q&A segments
on the regular podcast I'm going to
begin by contesting a premise of the
question and that is that we do in fact
maintain work/life balance so Eric when
did you go to sleep last night
approximately four am sick and still got
up at normal work time today
yeah I just generally don't sleep much
even if I try but what about you when
did you go to bed
yeah like 4:35 yeah yeah so yeah we
don't really do the whole work-life
balance thing we we have a corporate
culture that if you wrote it down on
paper would be it's like it's like
Industrial Revolution
turn-of-the-century stuff like yeah oh
my god yeah like if we forced someone
else to do it it would probably violate
some clause of the Geneva Convention
yeah which so okay let's nuance this a
little bit yeah I'm not recommending
this I do think that there is too much
of like a culture that glamorizes
working too much and just like
workaholism in general right and so I
don't want it to sound like we're doing
that because like I think it's bad but I
don't do it out of a sense of obligation
or that I think it's good I just kind of
like working yeah yeah I think you know
the way I put it a couple weeks ago when
we were talking to somebody it's not
when it's 2:00 in the morning and you
realize you're gonna be up till 4:00
you're not thinking you know if I don't
stay up till 4:00 the company's gonna
fold I'm not gonna be able to you know
support myself or you know some project
is gonna just absolutely crumble in our
hands you don't go to sleep because
you're like I'm on a roll baby like how
could I possibly go to sleep when I've
got all these ideas rattling around in
my head yeah or when I'm you know really
really locked in to what I'm doing and
so it's the the difference is I would
never you know the the term I always see
on the Internet is grind there's no
friction there's there's no grinding
going
yeah it's it's it's it's very well
lubricated exactly we just like what we
do and one of the things I've talked to
people about work/life balance in the
past and and generally speaking I think
it's a great idea I think you I think
you listening should have it I've tried
it I hated it
yeah well I'm so here's what I'll say
about my life recently I'm doing I am
doing a much better job with work/life
balance then I have previously but like
pretty frequently if there's something
I'm working on when Lindsey goes to
sleep and I say like look I'm trying to
finish this one thing up it's only gonna
be another like 30 minutes to an hour
very frequently when that happens I see
like some light coming through the
windows and it's like 6:30 I'm like well
[ __ ]
that wasn't an hour but it is just like
I get so engrossed in what I'm doing and
so sucked into it that I have difficulty
pulling myself away like you said it's
not grinding at all like I'm already
very tired but I would rather do this
than sleep which maybe that's a
pathology I don't know again we're not
saying this is necessarily a good thing
but I think it's to some degree just how
both of us are wired yeah I mean like
you said I think if can you imagine if
we just put out a call it be like hey
anybody want to join the gang and just
like the only real requirement is like
it'd be great if you were available at
2:30 in the morning for like just like a
random idea oh yeah if I see something
interesting in a paper I'd like to be
able to bounce it off of you two three
four in the morning you can't really put
that in the the call for applications
right but no I mean one of the things
that I really struggle with is it's a
different look at at work-life balance
it's not like anybody's making me do it
or even suggesting I do it but when I
try to make myself
really restrict my work hours or you
know stop saying yes to stuff you know
like oh and make sure that make sure the
reader earth not the readers the
listeners know this like I message you
probably once a month to say like dude
you seem really tired yeah like you're
doing a [ __ ] ton of work like if you
need to do less that's fine yeah like I
am NOT forcing this on you no no not at
all I mean you said that like the other
day like two days ago
no it's just I really like this stuff
and I have a very restless mind so when
I've tried to force myself to have more
work-life balance it's really
challenging because I'm like well I'm
supposed to be enjoying life right now
but I'd really love to be doing some
work because that's like a really
exciting fulfilling part of my life I
enjoy doing that stuff so I've never
really I still haven't figured out how
to make that work where you're supposed
to stop doing the stuff that you really
like and want to keep doing I don't know
maybe that's maybe that's bad what do
you think so this isn't an answer to
that question it's one of my just
general hot takes about this whole topic
yeah so virtually I I think that people
have a finite amount of hashtag grind in
them and I think that most of that is
motivated either by economic necessity
like they find themselves in a situation
where unless they do a lot of very
unpleasant stuff they're either going to
have to go some other direction with
their life which they think will be even
more unpleasant or like they're gonna
have a hard time making ends meet so
like I did do that for a while like
after college for for a bit finances
were were pretty tight and I did a fair
amount of work that I enjoyed and a fair
amount of work that I didn't enjoy but
it was just like you know like
got to do it and I think that the other
reason why someone might like hashtag
grind a lot is if they're like I guess
like kind of trying to keep up with the
Joneses but the Joneses aren't your
next-door neighbors like it's everyone
on Instagram yeah and you feel like you
know if I don't have to vacation homes
and three Ferraris then I'm a failure in
life like I think that there's some
degree of that as well beyond that
virtually everyone who's out there
talking about grinding they're not
[ __ ] doing it especially if it's like
internet entrepreneurs
most of them probably enjoy what they're
doing and most of them probably probably
enjoy their job more than you do yeah
cuz like dude if if you want to talk
about grinding like it's a grind to be a
[ __ ] retail worker like yeah it's
it's just like day-to-day people in the
economy who are doing something that
does actually strongly approximate
grinding like right the the people like
you know taking pictures of themselves
like with a laptop by the pool talking
about like dude you gotta you gotta get
out there and hashtag rise and grind
like dude shut the [ __ ] up
like you have the easiest life in the
world ya know I guess that's that is a
good distinction because I also had a
period in my life where I very much
would say I was grinding grad school
there was some grinding going on for
sure you know like it was that that same
kind of thing where it's like some of
the stuff was really fun some of the
stuff wasn't that fun but you got to do
it and it's it's a lot of work and I
think maybe part of that has framed the
way I look at it now is that now all of
it is exciting and fun and like
intellectually stimulating so it's hard
to even pretend that you're grinding
when you're like dude look what I'm
doing for my this is awesome like my new
version of
grinding is I found some statistical
concept to be intriguing so I simulated
a data set and now I'm playing with it
yeah just to see what happens yeah like
I guess that's grinding but it's really
just a curmudgeon tinkering around at
3:00 in the morning because he is just
really excited about it yeah but yeah
Eve if you want to talk about grinding
talk to a single mother with two kids
working a blue-collar job like right
there they're grinding harder than
anyone who is talking about grimy on
Instagram yeah it's a to get back to the
topic I think like the the concept of
work-life balance I'm just not sure it
applies that much to people like you and
me who are doing something that we
genuinely find to be fun mm-hmm like I
think it makes a lot more sense when you
are actually grinding and it's like dude
you need to step away from that like for
your own good
if you if you can afford to you know if
you can it's gonna be good for your
mental health and your well-being being
to just not be doing that for someone
texts amount of time yeah but but no I
mean it's just it's just really fun
so work-life balance for us is
negligible let's expand the topic of
work of work-life balance and talk about
general macroeconomic trends that sounds
fun doesn't it so if you ever have time
you should go back and read read like
pamphlets and documents of people
interested in or covering or involved in
the labor movement in America Europe
like really pretty much anywhere in the
world around around the turn of the 20th
century up until about the time the
Great Depression happened and I think
it's interesting reading kind of what
they viewed the goal of like the economy
to be so one thing to keep in mind just
kind of historically speaking
is the concept of work-life balance and
just like leisure time in general that's
an incredibly new concept
so like hunter-gatherers had a fair
amount of leisure time but then you know
a lot of babies died and a lot of people
died of infectious disease really young
and then like Agricultural Revolution
happened and like people would have some
downtime but it was basically like you
know you had to to work enough to tend
your fields and raise your livestock and
whatnot and then fast-forward to
industrialization like basically there
was a leisure class who did have like a
fair amount of leisure time like a lot
of them were folks who had previously
like had landed nobility under the
feudal system and still had a lot of
wealth from that or people who were very
early factory owners who ended up making
a ton of money from that or people who
got who got into the colonialism game
early and bought in on like early
joint-stock companies that ended up
returning ridiculous profits it's like
there was a very small minority of the
population that did have leisure time
and a considerable amount of it and
everyone else kind of looked at it and
they're like look dude like we don't
mind working a lot but like weekends
would be pretty nice or like you know a
10-hour workday well it was a 12-hour
workday than it was a 10-hour workday
and then it became an 8-hour workday
like you know we want to see our family
sometimes we would sometimes like to
have a day where we don't have to go
into work and so a lot of the things
that the early labor movement was
pushing for it was essentially like we
want more leisure time like we don't
necessarily have to make an enormous
amount of money to live like kings
during our leisure time we just want
time that we don't have to be working
that we can spend the family
and so like the Great Depression kind of
that took a reasonable amount of steam
out of the labor movement and then World
War two like that diverted everyone's
attention from you know whatever they
were worried about domestically to the
world war as it were but like prior to
that people were just like look people
are getting like industry is getting
more and more efficient the like median
profit that like workers can generate
with a given hour of work is going up as
technology improves and mechanization
keeps progressing it's like you know we
have an eight-hour workday and two
weekend days now maybe we should try to
push for a six-hour workday or like you
know a four hour work day or we only
work four days a week and have Wednesday
off as well so like for a while they're
like people did want better working
conditions and better wages but one of
one of the goals was we want more
work-life balance we want to be able to
use like the proceeds of technology and
mechanization to you know have a
slightly better standard of living but
also not have to work as much and really
ever since post-world War two a lot of
the focus just in society as a whole has
shifted away from that where it's like
okay we seem fairly chill with a 40-hour
workweek so now we just want our
standards of living to be as high as
possible with a 40-hour workweek instead
of saying like we're fine kind of
freezing our standards of living while
working less which which was something
that people used to be a lot more
receptive to which I don't necessarily
know what people listening to this can
do with it but I think it's worth you
know just kind of squirreling away in
the back of your mind because that is
that that is a motivation that a lot of
people seemed to have previously found
more compelling that in the post-war
years folks more or less just seem to
have forgotten about yeah let me ask you
this
going from general to personal here if I
if I asked you to not do any work
anything that would fall under the work
umbrella for four days how would you
feel by day four by day four I'd be fine
I don't think I believe you
no no so our our maximum vacation length
is like six days okay so by day six I'm
starting to really get the itch yeah but
I mean again like dude we are incredibly
fortunate correct um you know if I was
taking a vacation and I was going back
to if I was going back to a job where
someone was telling me what to do no
matter what that thing was I would I
would want to work way less and take a
longer vacations
everybody knows Lindsey calls the shots
I don't know what you're talking about
well she gives me the illusion of
control yeah well she gave me a deadline
she said last night I need this done by
exactly 405 a.m. and I mean I barely got
it in that's a [ __ ] lie
no but no I think when it comes to
work/life balance I think you know it's
kind of a personal thing you know it's a
matter of how you enjoy spending your
day I think sometimes it is funny that
people who just really love their work
kind of feel guilty like I'm doing too
much of the stuff I really enjoy so so I
think there are certain circumstances
where it's like you know you should feel
encouraged to fill your day however
however you want to as long as you're
not like shirking major responsibilities
I feel you there all right so work-life
balance just came to the wrong place I
think unfortunately yeah I think we can
all agree it's a scam I think so yeah
all right well we're right about an hour
here you think that I think that
probably does that right I I think as as
the host I'm the one who can make the
decision I think that's appropriate but
I was as the co-host I'll allow you to
have that
I was independently thinking on my own
that it was about time to wrap it up as
well so yeah this was the first fireside
chat episode of the stronger by science
podcast if you enjoyed it yeah I mean
like if you enjoy these episodes or the
regular episodes leave a rating on
iTunes or stitcher or wherever you get
your podcast from that really helps us
out if you're listening to this on
YouTube god I [ __ ] hate myself for
saying this like comment subscribe
it does actually help and yeah if you
did enjoy it leave us feedback wherever
you leave feedback whether that be in a
review for the podcast and a comment on
YouTube and a comment on Facebook or
Instagram let us know if you like the
style of content let us know what other
ideally non fitness related questions or
topics you'd like to see us address and
we will chat with you again in the next
episode thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another health
care professional if you enjoyed this
podcast and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science com2 check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you